the great Jackie Chan let me tell you my
story
working with religion a living legend
was amazing a living legend every day I
couldn't wait to come on the set to see
Jackie Chan I was late most of the time
but when I got there Jackie was there
waiting with his legs crossed and
where's Chris Sacca
we are late you know but he didn't
complain you know he knew I was this
young kid who you know didn't know his
lines but he went with the flow Jackie
is just it was just an honor working
with you and I can't wait to work with
you again and you you work with so many
other actors too you made a lot of
people rich Jackie a lot of people rich
no bonused Lee working with Jackie got
me global notoriety - from the rush hour
movies you might have seen automatically
working with a global star like Jackie
Chan so I was blessed night and I just
think I think you fetch a key thank you
for blessing me on that on that front
but Jackie I love you man you're part of
me I thank you
CheY CheY and congratulations and I'm so
thrilled and honored to be a part of
this to present you my good friend
Jackie Chan with the honorary Oscar
ladies and gentlemen give it up for
Jackie Chan